hey everyone this is steve wondrough
with collider and i am thrilled
to be with the cast of strange new
worlds one of my favorite shows on
television i want to thank you so much
for coming to the collider media studio
whatever the hell we're calling this i
just want to say a sincere thank you um
uh what has it actually been like for
you guys here at comic-con have you done
your panel yet i apologize for not
knowing are you yeah
yeah oh really so what is are you guys
ready for like the experience you're
about to have because you it's going to
play like a rock concert when you guys
come out on the stage yeah i have no
obviously anson and ethan and paul are
all but me me and sally it's our first
kind of property with star trek so it's
like i have no real idea of what it's
going to be like um it's our first real
in-person interaction with the fans so
on this massive of a scale this is sort
of our our first uh uh
i don't know gathering after the the
seasons come out and and i i i'm not
prepared for what's about to happen i'm
excited but uh excited terrified a
little nauseous but like
really really excited the thing that's
really hard to pull off like i so many
people i know love your show myself
included do you have you been paying
attention to just because fandom really
loves it i'm just curious if you guys
have been
do you read that stuff or not at all
a little bit yeah i mean i i
i don't know i i come from the theater
and you you typically you
you learn not to read your own reviews
and never believe the ones that are
really really great or never believe the
ones that are really really bad but i
sort of i guess i've gotten to the point
where i can separate myself from all
that and i just want to get a
temperature gauge for
fan reaction especially
uh with a show like this that has such a
built-in
fan base and really culture
uh you just i just wanted to get a sense
of what what nails were hitting
so uh yeah a little bit for fans of the
show
and for myself i love learning about
like the behind the scenes of the making
of a series or a movie
so what do you think fans of the series
would be surprised to learn about the
actual making of the show
sally and i um dance a lot at each other
from our chairs on the bridge so we
threw lots of shapes at each other
throwing shapes a lot of dancing a lot
of movement trying to stay like up and
animated during those like 14-hour
bridge days so uh uh there's a lot of
goofiness and shenanigan read that goes
on
when we're not sure they've taught me
some
oh yeah we taught him the chorus line
dance yeah yeah which ethan will be
doing at the panel
please tell me you have video of this
and are putting it
to try online i think so i would not
participate you tried to film it
secretly we'll get it yeah okay if we
don't have it now we'll get it to you by
next time by this time next year you'll
have it is there any other surprising
things people might be you know for
behind the scenes stuff you and i have a
hard time getting through a scene no
tree
we literally will say
for like hours like people are not happy
[Laughter]
a lot of people get annoyed
you're gonna get to see more of this
ship
uh as the show progresses we get to
build more of the enterprise and so
we're getting to see some of that some
of it's been released online already but
oh and that rooner my dog
she is actually anson's girlfriend
[Laughter]
she comes to set she's like the set
mascot and she everybody loves her spock
will play raccoon with her you know and
everybody you love her don't you i do
you tune up and
yeah she's like she's always around
running around one of the things that's
so interesting about strange new worlds
is that while everything is pushing to
being serialized the the show is
episodic and i love it because uh i just
love it and you guys get to it's almost
like a pilot every week you know and so
can you sort of talk about that aspect
of the series because a lot of people
might see this interview and actually
have not seen the show yet yeah our
showrunner akiva talks a lot about the
the freedom that that that brings which
is
you wouldn't expect it seems like a more
it would be a more structured thing or
less freedom but actually
when you have a new story
every week or a new planet every week
you can also change the mode
and the tone and so we've been really
pushing the boundaries with that in the
second season
and and seeing how many different
kinds of genres and things we can get
away with and
being able to invite many different
kinds of directors with many different
kinds of styles it's just been a joy
where are you actually in the filming
process of season two
we're done oh yeah we finished we
wrapped at the end of june
i'm trying i'm looking at my clock in my
head and i'm realizing got it uh three
weeks ago right so what
it feels like forever
what can you actually what are you
allowed to say about season two
coming at some point
that's what we can tell you i mean
listen it's obviously gonna be next year
because of the vfx involved in making a
series like this but uh if you can how
is it different from the first season um
is it what did you guys learn making the
first season that may be carried over
into the second season
henry describes season two as season one
on steroids yeah yeah and i think that's
probably the most accurate way to put it
yeah i agree it takes everything to
another level
and uh
for example the fantasy episode episode
eight which was kind of like a kind of
came out of nowhere
that will be topped oh yeah
yeah yeah in season two
um i am curious how kirk plays in in
season two as he was a late addition
yeah
i said in a previous interview that the
success of season one is solely on my
you know my 14 minutes of screen time in
the finale um no i'm excited because
season the finale of um season one was
was you know obviously based on balance
of terror which was the original series
episode which was quite a intense
episode and so i'm looking forward to
season two because kurt gets to kind of
let loose a little bit have a little
more fun and and and be a little and not
and not be alt future timeline kirk he
gets to be you know young kirk um um in
in the original series canon so um i'm
excited to explore that if you don't
mind i want to do a follow-up kirk is
one of the iconic characters in sci-fi
what was it like for you the night
before the first day of filming did you
sleep at all you know how were you
thinking about approaching it the the
when i had my meeting with with henry
and akiva um it was just
you know the the big sort of thing was
just like
don't try to do a shatner impression
don't you know don't
take what's been already done and try to
do your own spin do your own thing do
what basically do whatever you want is
really kind of they really entrusted me
and so i didn't have that pressure of
having to fit you know obviously or
working within parameters but you know
it's an alt timeline it's an old future
and really they were like just do your
own thing because
and it'll take time but eventually that
will be that version of kirk and so it's
really about kind of respecting it but
not trying to mimic it one of the other
things i really love is the way that uh
pike is dealing with the future and you
know he knows what's coming tried to
even possibly alter it can you sort of
talk about that aspect because it's it's
just a great i think it's just
something everyone would think about if
i know
my horizon is this what would i do
yeah i mean it's one thing to say that
you've accepted something and it's
another thing to actually accept it and
so that's the
the journey for pike in in season one
and i think ultimately it's a successful
one he gets to the point where i think
that
uh you know i've i
i've had the honor of meeting a
couple people in my life with terminal
diagnoses
who will say i've never been more alive
because i i know the end point and i
know how many days i have left and i'm
going to live them to my to my fullest i
think that we're going to get to see
more more fully realized more accepting
pike who's making the most of out of
what he has left but one of the things i
really love about the show is the fact
that like there's great writing between
all the characters and it just it's
unusual sometimes in the first season of
a show to have it where the writers feel
like they know these characters and the
actors feel like they have these
characters so can you sort of talk about
what it was like reading these scripts
how much did was did it end up being
like rainbow color scripts by the time
you're filming or was do you know what i
mean like the behind the scenes of the
writing
um i i gotta say it's it it uh you do do
shows where you get the rainbow of
colors and because there's so many
rewrites but
um on this show we we didn't go through
too many colors i mean they were they
were very confident scripts
um that came to us pretty well realized
you know yeah so much so in fact that uh
you know they won't release to us like
everyone else on set will be like have
you seen the next episode and we're like
no
and everybody else gets it before us for
that reason because they want them to be
super polished so we can prepare i guess
more precisely more accurately but yeah
they they kind of don't really do big
um
revisions for the screen but they're
really good this this writing team
they're really good about getting us the
scripts at at least
a week early for the most part yeah yeah
so because some you there you'll be on
shows where you'll get the script the
night before sometimes there'll be a
rewrite the day of and
but they they've really protected our
our preparation time for each of you
talk a little bit about what you and
it's a little generic but i i want to
ask it anyway what you really love about
the character you play like what you
relate to
and because you i really love your
performances on the series i would say
the the thing that i love about uhura
where we meet her um and and not who she
ends up being is we see her
sort of second guess herself which is a
very human thing i think so much about
starfleet is is perfect and and
it's when you think of starfleet you
think of people who are at the the best
of what they do and at the top of their
game and we know who who is going to be
and who she's going to grow into and the
fact that we see her second-guess
herself like any human would it's her
her humanity and her humility that that
i really really love
i with lyan i love uh
covering her vulnerability like you know
she's a fighter she's got all this stuff
going on but she's fighting to win over
it and even though she you know she has
this ptsd and whatever she's at the core
of it she
she wants to grow she wants to learn she
wants to move beyond her her past so to
play the conflict of that
of the barrier that she has the bravado
and also the
the soft inner world of her is is really
interesting for me
you want to go sure i
guess i mean i can go i think you should
go i'll go first feel good about you
guys
for uh for all of spock's uh precision
and certainty
and his knowledge in a given situation
and just the breadth of knowledge he has
about physics and science he's sort of
an answers guy in a lot of situations
he's so deeply uncertain and i really
love that contrast and kind of
discovering those moments of uncertainty
and
letting that inform who he is
um yeah i think for for kirk you know
one of the sort of pillars of of that
character is that he really does have a
unique internal instinct that is his
guiding light and that really that
instinct is something that if he taps
into he really does listen to that um
and and it really does guide him in the
in the correct direction and that's
something that i relate to is that i do
think a lot of us know what to do uh
deep down inside but we second guess
ourselves a bazillion times and i think
kirk is someone who just relies on his
instinct and he makes those decisions
and they work out um so i i love that's
probably my favorite thing about the
character i can relate to i just love
our writer's instinct to make pike the
really the first
captain we've seen
who has the ability to turn to his crew
and go i have no idea what's going on
does anybody have any idea
best idea wins go that's if pike had a
superpower it would be turning that
bridge crew into a big brain
you know and i just i think it makes for
much more exciting bridge scenes that
way i know that a lot of people are
gonna love the action scenes or when two
characters are on a planet doing
something but like some of my favorite
stuff was or one of my favorite scenes
and i forget what episode number it was
but it's when everyone is going to the
captain's quarters to have a meal and
it's all the characters together getting
to talk and it's like i mean so but i
also know a lot of actors and they tell
me those dinner scenes or eating scenes
suck
they are the worst because you have to
decide what you're going to actually eat
do you show up hungry do you show up
full like are you spitting in a bucket
so can you sort of talk a little bit
about filming
like eating scenes and also filming that
scene because it's just that's the stuff
i love it's when the characters are all
interacting i think i was uh flying the
ship in that scene yeah was that episode
two
of the one where uh before ortega's uh
uh pranks uhura when she's wearing her
dress uniform is that this yeah that's
episode two um and that scene i
think they went very easy on me i only
had a little thing of tea because i was
so very anxious and i think if her ate
anything she'd immediately get sick um
not because pike's cooking would make
her sick but because she is so nervous
about what's happening um i i love
dinner scenes i love scenes where we're
all together and like interacting
because the way we shoot sometimes
you'll only see like one person for the
whole day depending on the scenes that
are going on those big scenes obviously
they take a lot of time but they're fun
yeah but they're fun it's like a summer
camp
that's what it feels like to me i don't
know there was a scene where babs had to
be like wolf babs who plays doctor and
manga was had to be wolfing down like
waffles and bacon yeah and it was i felt
really bad for him
because he went for it from the first
take yeah well i i know some people uh
like joel kinnaman was telling me on for
all mankind when there's like food
scenes he just eats he's like he's like
i have five meals i don't care and other
people i know are like i don't take a
bite like it goes right out so
i know you must have all have filmed a
food scene at one point what's your
secret to the food scene
i just go for it
so you eat oh yeah i know there's one
scene um uh in our when you're about to
um uh how me about those data chips
episode six episode six and i'm just
wolfing down these noodles and dumplings
and i just went for it cause it's yummy
it was but uh i just i i think i go for
it just cause it's it's i don't know i'm
a huge fan of like
head first go for it and see what sticks
yeah i take small bites of his food and
if it's if it's drink then it's some
version of water
i'm sensible like i just remember though
when i learned uh when i learned about
being careful how much you're eating in
a scene was
when i did crossroads and we had a scene
in a waffle house and i love waffle
house
and i knew exactly what i wanted to
order right and we must have shot that
scene
32
times i ended up eating
13 trucker specials
and
and by so by there are some there are
some cutaways in that scene where i'm
sitting next to to britney spears and
i'm just like just
[Laughter]
and then after we finish i had to go
into the men's room and and
had a night on the town in new orleans
[Laughter]
do you guys want to add oh um
what it's always brothers
that's right it's my own whiskey and
that's uh it's a secret to kirk um
no that'd be nice though um yeah well
actually i did a big food scene in
season two yes you did um
huge spoiler by the way yeah yeah
massive spoiler yeah yeah i'm gonna get
a call from paramount um
no and uh what a lot of like air chewing
air chewing and then uh you know spit
bucket but sometimes you're just hungry
sometimes you're just hungry man and i
was hungry remember you had the
vegetables instead your vegetables what
are you doing remember when you had the
radishes
oh yeah radishes and carrots that was it
yeah yeah yeah there's a in a wide shot
in a wide shot that i they give you all
this like heavy food and i was like give
me something that's like i'm not gonna
if i if i do it 20 takes so i had like
radishes and cucumbers that i sort of
pretended were my main meal and it
worked in the wide and i was really
eating that with a lot of
[Laughter]
my oh yeah my secrets
i have a scene in season two where i
have to eat a lot of something kind of
disgusting
and i had a spit bucket and um
it was a it was a it was a crime scene i
mean
doing a lot of drinking a lot of eating
remembering we're all at the table
uh so what is it like a lot of shows and
i'm curious what it is for for your show
some shows are you know a seven day
shoot eight day shoot ten day shoot what
is it actually for strange new worlds
and does it depend on the episode
uh
average is
uh
about 12.
maybe a bit more than that because we do
have a couple episodes that go closer to
15.
not including second unit sure but is
that a result because of covid and the
precautions or is that just because it
takes that long that's the that's the
trick of making an action adventure show
set in a series of little rooms and
hallways it just takes longer i'm very
curious about the t-shirt what was the
motivation for star trek five because i
love it and i also love that it's the
japanese version
i just love wearing i like i feel like
i'm on the coolest team in the world and
i love like i haven't been on this team
in a long time and so to be able to like
wear
gear for my team authentically like i
just enjoy that so much and this i
actually got um we did our first
appearance as a castle with celia
at uh mission chicago which is a like a
cbs sponsored uh convention
and um
it's just it's from there and uh i think
it's cool
ethan has a series of like really
awesome star trek shirts that he like
has a closet of i'm building i'm
building a collection yeah yeah they're
they're pretty sick that's gonna be
massive i'm gonna give you a pointer and
i don't know if you've done it already
but they still some places online still
sell iron-on t-shirts if you can find
them because the iron-ons are like you
know over time they wear out but if you
might be able to find some vintage trek
iron-on shirts which is something to
think about dry clean them get on it
he's on a mission establish the
collection no i'm being completely
serious there used to be a shirt a place
in vancouver
uh uh that i forget the name of it but
it was right in the main part of town
and it was i would always go in there
and was amazed at what they had but um
you're in you guys shoot in ontario
right yeah so it's yeah um on that note
i'm i've been given the hook so i'm just
gonna say
i love your show thank you so much for
coming in i wish you guys nothing but
the best i know your panel is gonna play
like a rock concert
really really enjoy it um thank you
thank you so much thank you